it is so good to see you ashley in
isolation right now
uh welcome to my house and i'm welcoming
myself into yours
how are you doing i'm good i think you
know
as best as you know you can be in this
situation obviously
everyone's going through it there's
highs there's lows
um but staying creative and
um and you know just kind of it's weird
how i've
acclimated so quickly to it in such a
weird way it's i've never been
right obviously i know same here
it's nice to be home with the kids right
now and i'm more excited to pack their
home because
this film is finally out uh nine years
since the last film five years since the
series ended was it
easy to get candidates out of you like
that inner feeling was it fair
you know i was really nervous because um
i just didn't know since obviously we
hadn't done the series in a while and i
was just like oh man am i going to be
able to find her like craziness
obviously i've gotten older i've grown
and
um likes to say i like said the first
thing and i was like completely
into it so um so
i just went back right you know candace
is is such a crazy character she's so
much fun
such a crazy character but i love the
way she sings such a beautiful day i'm
assuming you're probably humming that
song all day it's stuck in your head
how was it for you to create that song
it was fun you know obviously with the
music
um and i i do my own music
it's always so different because how i
approach the songs
in in this show and in this movie it's
like i'm playing my character so i have
to sing differently
than how i would normally um but such a
beautiful day is like one of the best
songs because it really embodies who
candace is as a person
and um it was fun you know it's always a
little bit
obviously um it's like at first hard
because i want to
i want to lay back in music usually as
an artist
yeah or you have to like make sure it's
alive and like you know you gotta like
with animation you're so much
bigger than like when you're on screen
for something so you really have to add
a lot of energy to the music
and and even to the character yeah i
love that and your character is very
loud
in another relationship with her brother
and she finally gets some space from her
brother
and it got me thinking about my brothers
and sisters when we were younger you
have an older sister
did you cling on to your sister or she
tell you always like go away
go away leave me alone yeah when i was
younger i definitely
probably the worst younger sister i
would always try to get my sister in
trouble
um but yeah i mean i was probably very i
mean i know i was like really annoying
and so she was
you know she wasn't as cool with me
until we got older and like i was in
high school
it was in college and then she was just
like okay you're cool now
but yeah i was definitely pretty
annoying
yeah my sister still picks me up picks
on me right now
i'm 40 and it's still it's still a thing
uh you know i love the way you did a
throwback to also to a cola dylan that
photo was so
cute and he kind of thinks about all the
the reunions would you ever work with
them again
oh i mean i love them they're they're
like they're like my
brothers so of course i mean i i would
always love working
i've been very lucky i've worked with a
lot of great people and that are
still my friends that i would love to
work with again
because uh all of them hold something
really special in my heart
yeah and your birthday happy belated
birthday
35 how did you celebrate um
i did a very like you know i did like a
very social
distanced um little kind of hangout in
my backyard
fully masked it was like five people
it's very small
but it's all people you know i i knew
we're taking it very seriously um so
yeah
it was just uh it was very different you
know obviously this year
and we celebrated your birthday at et
canada by showing some of your fashion
moments through your 35 years
and so i have to ask you the question
what is your favorite fashion moment
in your least fashion moment
oh my god i don't know but we should do
this so hard i'm like my
favorite fashion moment i think like one
of my favorite fashion moments was
probably
uh when i went and uh presented at the
tonys
um that was really cool because i loved
how it was like a
crop with like high-waisted pants that
look like a dress it was the most
comfortable thing i've ever worn in my
life at an event and so it's just like
this is definitely something i had so
much fun
obviously my least favorite is
i i i know it's a tough one like my
least favorite i think
in fashion everybody grows and grows up
and they always we always look back and
we're like what were we thinking but
like
my moments when i was younger are like
memes now because
everyone thinks it's hilarious and like
i think like i was very creative
you are her i love it i like i think
you know it's funny because i think
those moments when i was younger
wearing like the craziest stuff in the
2000s really encapture
a person who did not give anything like
like
and i think that is something that's
very uh
special because as we grow in this
business and the spotlight is on us we
tend to then be like oh what will people
think of this
and so i actually think it really
captures something that like was very
um you know just special at that point
in my life that like i really didn't
care what people thought and i wore
whatever i wanted
and i gotta say you are a tick-tock
queen
i mean you got it going like you're so
good at it
like how do you like how do you come up
with the ideas
do you have fun with it i mean bass like
i mean i
feel like tick tock is really about like
the trends of you know the dances
and that to me is really fun i think
that dancing i've always loved and so
i love doing like each of the you know
challenges of like
the dancing so i haven't really you know
i'm not a creator where i come up within
dances myself
but i really love being able to do
what you know like everyone else is
doing on it and it's just fun it's like
yeah it's just a fun time it's so easy
it's like i love how
it's doesn't you know you don't have to
like dress up for it you don't have to
put makeup on it's just a very like
real-time app like a social media app in
that way
you know everything's like picture
perfect
type of style and it's just like i love
how real tick-tock is
you're amazing so wonderful talking to
you and i can't wait for everyone to
see this film it's so good finally back
thank you guys thank you